just add water and throw on some instant
Underpants right after you sign this
bathroom guest book because loot is back
start your day with a cup of joe using
Canadian Oh a personalized wooden coffee
maker that uses a pour over coffee
method and is carved out of cherry
walnut or maple which over time slowly
absorbs the flavor of each cup you make
once it's ready drink it from the toasty
mug to keep your hands warm if there's
no time for coffee just add caffeinated
maple syrup to your breakfast that you
eat out of a bacon bowl or just wear
your breakfast with power baking
deodorant for when you sweat like a pig
pig out on glow-in-the-dark
ice cream at lick me I'm delicious a
portable ice cream company that will
come to your event and make awesome
frozen creations using either the Nitro
ice cream parlor or the Nitro ice cream
buggy Network like a carnivore during
your event by handing out some meat
business cards but be sure to charge
your iPhone first in this toaster dock
if you have a thing that needs to be
charged use the thing charger to charge
your things all of the things get back
to basics with one of these human
powered devices after tripling their
goal on Kickstarter the guys at pedal
power are now ready to create and ship
your personalized machine or choose from
their to stock products the big rig or
the pedal Jenny if you're pedaling a
bike use these turn signal gloves to be
safe they help you to be seen by
motorists with just the push of your
thumb then use your thumb to play with
your smart plane that is crash proof
connected instantly by touching your
phone to the plane and flies for half an
hour on a single charge charge it to
battle with this awesome rubber band
machine gun and do this to everything
let your feline friend battle this egg
cat toy that mimics and responds to your
cat like a smart little egg companion
see how smart your friends are by giving
them the gift of puzzles with this
cryptic puzzle pod that lets you set
your own five-letter code drink up with
this shark attack glass and use shark
fin ice cubes to keep your drink cold
act like a shark with face rig an
IndieGoGo campaign that lets you become
a character that even displays emotions
using just a webcam keep your feet warm
with these rechargeable heated insoles
or by using a fireplace anywhere with
the anywhere fireplace that you set up
on your light-up coffee table that lets
you choose your own colors and graphics
for the tabletop for some prehistoric
light use this Dino lamp or a wall torch
sconce that even detaches to take along
on your adventures and create the
perfect temperature with your bed jet
that goes from toasty to cool with the
touch of a button then cuddle up with
your custom stuffed animal made from
your childhood drawings courtesy of
budsies calm that may or may not end up
looking similar to these killer bunny
slippers which pair wonderfully with
enemy socks the smarty ring shows you
incoming and outgoing call notifications
alerts you to text messages and emails
and updates from social media and once
you're thirty meters away from your
phone it beeps to remind you but for a
mere nine hundred and forty-four dollars
you can own this meteorite and dinosaur
ring so tell everyone what's on your
mind with roller notes keep everything
else in this stuff I want to hide from
nosy people box and as always thanks for
watching